[Applaudissements]
après avoir été accueilli en héros au
Parlement européen volody mirzuelinski a
pris la parole ce jeudi devant les 27 de
lieu une intervention avec pour objectif
principal d'exhorter les dirigeants de
l'Union européenne accélérer les
livraisons d'armes pour son pays
nous avons besoin d'artillerie de
munitions de char moderne de missile à
longue portée d'avion de chasse moderne
merci de nous offrir le soutien
militaire que vous nous offrez merci
d'en faire davantage nous devons aller
plus vite que notre agresseur
une liste non exhaustive des besoins
militaires urgents de l'Ukraine en
réponse à la nouvelle offensive russe
lancée dans l'est du pays mais la
demande reste ambitieuse selon le
président français Emmanuel Macron qui a
averti que l'on voit des avions de
combat à Kiev ne seraient pas instantané
dans aucun cas des avions de chasse ne
peuvent être livrés dans les semaines
qui viennent parce qu'il y a des délais
de formation de livraison et formation
incompressibles pour des avions qui ne
sont pas connus des pilotes
ukrainiens et donc je ne l'exclut
absolument pas mais ça ne correspond pas
aujourd'hui aux besoins
une promesse prudente du soutien de
l'Union européenne qui craint que le
déploiement d'avion de combat
occidentaux débouche sur un conflit
ouvert entre l'OTAN et la Russie autre
point clé abordé par les 27 le 10e
paquet de sanctions de lieu contre
Moscou des sanctions qui s'ajoutent au
67 milliards d'euros de soutien octroyés
depuis le début de l'invasion en février
dernier
la Russie doit payer pour la destruction
causée et pour le sang versé dans les
prochains jours nous proposerons le
10ème paquet de sanctions premièrement
nous imposerons des sanctions à un
certain nombre de dirigeants politiques
et militaires nous ciblerons les
propagandistes du président russe parce
que leurs mensonge empoisonnent l'espace
public en Russie et à l'étranger
de l'Ukraine à l'Union européenne a
également été évoquée des négociations
pourraient débuter cette année